so 25 na wer fliegt man die lach mensch
der nachbar auch wieder zu später stunde
unterwegs
nokia mein haus wird schon was jetzt
nicht so gut wie das aussehen wird
ich bete ich also du wirst angezeigt
dass die 190 meter von mir entfernt so
viele kabel stone rein das ist
unglaublich dass man mit landesligist er
dass sich vom machen verdienen einfach
noch zu wenig energie
also ich krieg wirklich noch zu wenig
energie und du sollst dich im windkraft
technisch engagieren oder hauptsächlich
schreibt gerade mit ihnen verzauberten
schwerter dir spitzhacken solar helmi
cetera alles welt so bisschen
übertreiben jetzt schreibe ich passiert
mir 15 diaz und einen solar hält fest
dass ich dir wie so verliere ich hier
energie ach so ja weil die weil diese
teile gebaut werden so watase ok alles
klar doch sowieso ein energiespeicher
einfach mega viel energie dass du dich
erst mal weg kann man ja was mit dem
grill weiter und wir brauchen natürlich
machbar und oder ab zurück zum
grundstück zurück zum grundstück geht's
ab und ich war
ab zu dem grundstück das war bei access
und wir sind schlecht macht ja natürlich
kann ich hätte trotzdem gefallen ich
wollte das war auch der medien man muss
ja irgendwo jahre haben uns selber noch
kein youtube
also ich erwarte hier irgendwie mein
untergrund ich baue irgendwie auch nur
unten immer weiter ich hab irgendwie gar
keinen bock oben an der oberfläche zu
bauen
ich bin so ein kellerkind offensichtlich
ich hab wirklich mal was ist das
höchster effizienz was geht
weißt du hast das hat schon was denn die
höchste effizienz der zauberin gibt es
jetzt mal wirklich 54 oder das heißt es
nicht sich grob schätzen
ich habe überlegt wenn ich jetzt wird
gleich gerne wieder schlagen wieder
verzaubern einfach nur anzuschauen wenn
ich jetzt muss glück haben erstmal
effizienz rauskriegen dass wir ja wenn
ich dann klickt bei effizienz zwei jetzt
bekommen das heißt ich kann ja wenn ich
zweimal effizienz 21 uhr dann kriegt
effizienz daraus ja hocharbeiten sollte
und wieso möglich sein
und du kannst bei mir verzaubern der
laube stark
da hat sich schon mal nicht schlecht aus
sie müssen sich nur noch die wand
ausfüllen
also irgendwie sieht mein keller ich ja
aus wie die klinik weil einfach mal alle
wände immer weiß nicht ich mache ja
extra weißt was will ich mit dieser
sterilen atmosphäre erreichen im
ergebnis nicht entspannen
nein auch wenn man nämlich wieder das
andere rabatt fachmann jetzt brauche ich
hier noch so ein bisschen es sehr
ärgerlich so dann lade ich mir noch mal
kurz meiner change
zack zack zack
st
und jetzt wird abgebaut das fenster ist
ja für elektrische axt oder nicht ja und
was schere zusammen affäre auch das ist
geil
willst du mit einer kettensäge eine
chance wenn man darüber nachdenkt dass
minecraft wo eigentlich alles im viel
mehr kaputt geht wirklich schlecht da
lachen ja da brauche ich muss mir echt
gleich mal was zu essen machen ich
glaube wir gleichen kosten stopp machen
und mir ganz gut was manchen kohldampf
aber ich bin jetzt einfach gerade geil
diese mega maschinerie zu bauen das ist
es einfach gar nicht geil moment ja es
ist schon besonders die mutter gegangen
und ich sehe dass ich dachte ich bin ja
wie gesagt jetzt bei miramax
so weiß ich finde eines nicht hast du so
das ist irgendwie so ist als wenn
genau ja es ist so ist als wenn ich ganz
zeit rannte würde also ich meine franz
und passte zu hunt zurück kennst du hast
das dann so komisch du liegst du schon
im bett noch nicht so flott gehen hier
willst du willst doch klappen gehen ich
werde arbeiten im keller also ist mir
eigentlich ziemlich wurscht
ja ich gehe jetzt jeden moment so geht
schon mal rein
ich bin direkt und persönlich kann ich
nicht an hat die leitung nicht goldenes
transport wo genau das benötige ich und
ich war ein hölzernes transporte blick
so matt ja jetzt liege ich drin
komm ich bot jetzt eben hier mit
allerdings ab ich habe meine tänzer auf
gelernt
hier müssen sich jetzt langsam alles
aufladen jo effekt sie sich auch wieder
hier ist wirklich ziemlich duster
irgendwie da muss ein vergnügen so
perfekt wie baum war ist jetzt hab ich
brauche auf jeden fall holztransport
oder transport wurde weil nur holz kann
man mit dem electric and wind power und
da habe ich gesehen dass das die
elektrik engines sein muss sondern da
habe ich gesehen dass das auch mit dem
hier geht mit der red storm mit dem
retro motto wo einfach nur den hebel
brauchen was mega cello ist nur holz und
glas holz
daran hätte ich früher denken sollte
heute mein haus ist in bearbeitung
habe ich überhaupt irgendwelche seeds
irgendwas irgendwas was hier sinnvoll
ist ich verschenke immer meine ganzen
zeiten sollte immer zu bezahlen habe ich
nichts mehr
robert friedmann um alles holz eichen wo
ist die gute alte eiche die gute
deutsche eiche wo habe ich sie und jetzt
die deutsche eiche mache ich denke wenn
ich nicht so viel kohle einfahren
ich weiß noch gar nicht was mich zuerst
noch nicht überlegt jetzt schon mal was
mit zu machen
laut bewegung für alle was mache ich mir
zu essen ich denke jetzt mal laut nach
caps oder einvernehmlich mit dem auf das
richtig so warum nämlich mit genau was
ausgleich und setzte mich ja eigentlich
wurst wird nur aber ich habe doch wer
ich habe jetzt so viele kisten ich habe
den überblick verloren ehrlich gesagt so
geht
da hab ich holz gebaut doch nicht nur
okay gut
das habe ich gar nicht entlassen ok dann
nicht ein glas gefunden
doch irgendwas nicht so alt st
fragen in jeder kiste ist einfach mal
irgendwo zwei sand hier ist nicht die
art alter ja wenn jetzt auch nicht
sortiert das auch noch ein problem
müssen zehn kisten gucken ob ich
vielleicht ein bisschen was zusammen 1
der gesandte ja war etwa in den
regulären oben sagt das nicht passen und
26 mache ich mal so mal
auch mal hier waren heute blätter drin
wie so waren wir dann keine dingsda drin
ich schaue mal ganz großes conne 1 geht
egal also wir brauchen erstmal eine
fette kiste das heißt ich muss einfach
eine lehre nehmen havanna dir dazu ist
noch eine kabel stone rein wenn ich dann
sage okay jetzt ist abfahrt
das wird hier sage ich mal unsere küste
wo ich sage ich hier geht's los
das heißt man muss es so sein dass hier
ein hölzernes transporter ist dass jeder
eingebaut ist und dann auch dieses
bauteil das dann dementsprechend so
punkt wir sehen es punkt jetzt es ist
zwar langsames punkt wenn ich jetzt hier
ein tour müsst ihr das raus gesaugt
werden ja sehen ist da kommt es okay
meine meinen körper namens kolonie eins
arbeitet ist natürlich langsamer aber es
funktioniert wenn wir hier ein junkie
oder haben ist uns dass das heißt so ich
habe das ganze natürlich noch etwas
schöner bauen dass das reich hier hinten
ist sagt und zwar so uns dann einfach
das so auch ja da kann ich das so ganz
weg machen und dann einfach sage ich
mache drei tage geht hast du ja das
funktioniert so das heißt ich habe jetzt
schon mal in die kiste wo die items or
ausgesaugt werden brauche ich jetzt eine
automatische workbench und ich habe hier
irgendwo ganz viele stick ist gehabt ich
muss das jetzt alles einfach mal zu
bauen mit vereinigten vereine ich sage
ich hab mir irgendwo ganz viele stickies
gesehen
denn der kiste sind 23 das ist echt ne
marke also es ist der hammer
und jetzt muss man ganz kurz überlegen
wie ich das mache ich ihnen dass beide
nur am grübeln ich weiß es nicht ich
glaube ich habe einen plan
zack zack zack zack und wenn ich das hab
ich noch eine workbench und so manchmal
meine erste automatische workbench genau
ist oder ich mache einfach einen
kompletten glasboden alter dass wir auch
ich glaube das mache ich dann kann nicht
einmal runter drücken dann ist darunter
auch beleuchtet ja das eine gute idee
ist so dass hier darf noch kein glas
sein das muss das hier sein dass ich mir
den hintern darum das heißt dass ihr ach
das ist ja unglaublich wie weit mache
ich das ich mache das glaube ich drei
würde ich sagen ja 3 das heißt
man muss noch so viel machen
wie man daraus noch mal ich muss zu
feuerstein dass es vier sohn gelegt
alles klar das halte ich brauche
vielleicht holzbretter fällt mir gerade
auf die frage ist muss das gebaut werden
oder nicht glaubt hat so viel erreichen
16 nee ich bin selbst wenn ich jetzt
welche hätte also irgendwas wirkte alles
was kein dingsda ist was kein drama ist
ja aber ich glaube nicht
wir sind ja alle hin ich freue mich auch
warum ich einfach gar kein holz ab weißt
du wie die automatische werk bauen
funktioniert muss energie gefordert
seien oder nicht habe ich auch schon
gesagt guck mal im wiki einfach nach
schau mal kurz wie er ist es automatisch
wer krank wird ist toll und dachte mir
noch nicht mal dienstag gefunden sodass
muss wahrscheinlich auch eingegebene
auto muss ich dieses jahr
atomkraft ist das reines glück
wie funktioniert das ganze sitzen
schlagen die kraft menschen wird dort
kein place euch dass das so lassen
ich habe ich gar nichts mehr
doch ich glaube dass das so ist das so
weil wir hier kommt müsst ihr dass sie
ganz langsam raus pumpen richtig langsam
kann ich nicht rabatt zum normalen
gutmachen ich glaub nicht eichenholz
carita
82 stärker mini umstand machen wir auch
1 mini umstadt ist quasi unendlich
haltbar so genau aber ich habe leider
ohne motor war ich dem da war ich mit
einem kolben glas und fallstudien aber
ich verstehe nicht wieso ich wirklich
nichts habe
jedoch so vieles
muss noch mal ganz genau schauen sich
rawert rieslinge die habe ich auch noch
so großzügig verschenkt und somit nie
was zurück schenken
für robert schenk ich dir schenke ich
dir etwas zu klein
das ist normal das ist hier geben und
nehmen
das ergebe ich bin mir ziemlich jetzt
alle kisten ganz genau durch geschaut
habe und ich bin nur ein holz gefunden
zwischen bin schon mal das ist das
rezept für einen erzähle ich die kurzen
den urwald und simon hat ein paar baum
richtig schön gemacht mit den blättern
finde ich geil aus ich hab mein glück
ist die bisher an behinderten aus meinem
haus wird auch noch gelb ich stelle mich
jetzt einmal irgendwo in den dschungel
und fahren und abfangen abzubauen aber
nicht so nahe bei mir das einzige dingen
weswegen ich respekt hab eigentlich
dürfte ich das machen ist ja genau das
gleiche wie wenn er das mit atomenergie
macht könnte aber mit dem laser die
bäume abbauen und dann einfache
riskieren dass abzubilden und irgendwo
brennt das duo simon darüber wenn die
wir pech haben es hier genau das gleiche
wie mit den als dunkerbeck
aber das war auch nicht so nah bei mir
ab ich war so ob das was keiner sieht ja
gut so kann es ja so ein fetter bau oder
wird jetzt abgeholzt 3 x 3 bio
was ich brauche
mein gott ich brauch noch viel mehr
sonderlich viel mehr ich kann ich
übrigens auch schon der abgrund hier
haha bitte auf zu pfeifen dann fängt an
mit frauchen du wirst wiebels laut ohne
witz ja noch nie so hohe ton
naja wird das nicht so weit weg aber ich
bin viel zu weit weg
ja okay ich mache hier hausbau von daher
obwohl ich mache ausbau erwarten war
nickte ich sowieso gleich zu ende ich
will noch kurz hier im ganz klein wenig
holz sammeln und dann komme ich ja auch
geschafft
also so kriegt man echt gut holz und 3 x
3 mm ist noch grösser vier mal drei oder
so überbau malta der ultimative killer
baum
ich geh jetzt ab ja die party egal ob du
ich freue mich doch essen sagt wie
sollte das machst du dir denn zu essen
vielleicht kann ich mir da ein beispiel
dran nehmen wollen wir später die sonne
gut so seit ich fliege jetzt noch nach
hause da können wir ein kettchen setzen
und so und ich habe insgesamt
mitgenommen 26 holz
das ist so gut wie das ist rambos durch
doch gesagt kannst du mir geben ich
brauche ein paar das kann ich kein
normales volk machen ja ja ich weiß was
das für eine scheiße hat sie mir
vielleicht ein ganz paar geben nur die
folge sind nicht vorbei schauen weiter
ganz ehrlich ich habe da gar 26 von
gefahren ich werde noch mal in die lava
gib mir doch einfach kacke ist das denn
bring mir das bitte im dann vorbei wenn
da hier direkt in der nähe sieht gar
nichts als einfach nur ein bisschen holz
ist das zu viel verlangt
mitleid und da hat mich im dschungel
gehen visa ist ja da ist ja nur dieses
komische holz dann irgendwie so gibt es
ja keinen tropenhaus also tropenholz zu
ein bisschen zufällig ist völlig egal
welches holz aber rabatte alter wirklich
die ddr chef günther ist ich hab mich
schon gewundert wieso ein megabyte
überhaupt existieren kann dass so ein
fake baum ist das was aber machen oder
was es da was mögliche weiß ich auch
nicht so schön aus schau mal kurz was da
was möglich ist
man kann
oder wird kann also nur deko ja dann
bringt das doch bitte im vorbeigehen
jetzt hier wie gesagt muss jetzt den
baum hinauf kompletten alter freunde das
passt perfekt mit dem mit dem neuen
leiter ja und das passt genau perfekt
sondern richtig richtig fehler gemacht
und es passt einfach perfekt abgezählte
dazu fall zu fall einfach ja dann gehe
ich jetzt alleine eben auf dem baum und
hollywood und wurde gut und so nahm es
nicht mehr weiter oder ja muss ich fragt
mama einfach optimal kurz was machen
kann dann ist das vielleicht schon
fertig werden so wären wie ich nach
hause
jetzt kann ich das welchen werden darin
da ich dafür nicht passt wir stellen
kugel und darf mich falls man doch keine
geräusche machen bilder junger halten so
25 muss reichen
wer fliegt nach mensch der nachbar auch
wieder zu später stunde unterwegs
hier mein haus wird schon was jetzt so
viel wie das aussehen wird nach den
miesen bauchklatscher auf
da ja warum
was ist ein krieg hinter dir danke so
ich hab das rot hingeworfen ist ein
steak oder so
jetzt brauche ich auch nicht mehr
arbeiten kann man ja immer mal
gebrauchen immer schön loben also ich
glaubte einer der einzigen den
niedersten ring mit monster natürlich
aber immer im keller sitzen oft
gestorben ist und sich die monster nicht
hin da kann man jetzt auch und kettchen
machen ja dann in der nächsten folge
werdet ihr dann sehen wie man haus
aussehen wird und es wird technisch
werden es wird episch wären dann lasst
doch eben noch canyons wände der folge
alles klar da sage ich gute nacht und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal bleibt
geil ich vor hunger gleich